هذا الهاجس المعرفي الذي لديك او تلك
الحيره تلك الاسئله التي سكنت كم مبكرا
كيف تكونت هل هناك احد من العائله يهتم لا
لم يكفي في العائله احد مهتم او عنده
اشتغال معرفي في هذه القضيه لكن
يعني شخصيه امي وابي كانت
يعني شخصيه شخصيات تتصل بالوجود بطريقه
عميقه جدا وكان هناك حكمه حكمه معيشيه
الان انتبه لها يعني بعد هذا العمر
واتعملها سواء في اللغه ولا في الذكريات
ولا في الحديث فهذا يمكن الخبره الوجوديه
اشرت الى الفلسفه الوجوديه تعيدنا الى
تامل الانسان
في خبره اعمق من الخبره المعرفيه والفكريه
هناك ما هو اعمق الاتصال الوجودي بالكون
منذ الصغر انا كان لدي رغبه ان نجيب على
اسئله
كنت الكتابه كانت هي
المزرعه هي يعني هي الوسيله اللي من
خلالها حاول ان اجيب على هذه الاسئله لكن
كلما كتبت كنت اكتشف مقدار الجهل عندي
وتتسع هذه الدائره وكنت حقيقه يعني لدي
رغبه عميقه في فهم الخبره الانسانيه يعني
هذا هذا اللي كان يشغلني عشان كذا كان
علاقتي مع الروائي نجيب محفوظ علاقه عميقه
جدا لانه هو فيلسوف وجودي انا من وجهه
نظري رواياته كلها نماذج للتامل الوجودي
في الحياه وفي الانسان هناك روح تسكنه كنت
ابحث عنها
فعرفت ان انه درس البكالوريوس طبعا في
الفلسفه
نعم
فقلت ربما هذا هو
نجيب يعني نعم ما كانت دراسه الفلسفه
متاحه في السعوديه
لكن القراءه الكتب لحسن الحظ انها كانت
موجوده وكانوا الاساتذه الكبار مثل
الدكتور سعيد السريحي الدكتور سعد البازعي
الدكتور معجب الزهراني كانوا هم هم
الاساتذه اللي كانت الفلسفه ايضا تمر من
خلالهم لنا ثم بعد ذلك حصلت الفرصه
نعم عندنا الابتعاث في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عن
واجه هذا الباب اللي باب قسم الفلسفه فكان
كان مقفل والان هو مفتوح والان امامي الان
مطلوب مني ان افتح الباب فاذكر اني التقيت
باحد الاساتذه
بريطاني لكن يدرس في امريكا
فقلت له انا اريد ان ادرس الفلسفه اريد ان
ادخل في برنامج الماجستير عندكم
فقال عندنا شرط نحن لابد ان يكون لديك 12
ساعه اكاديميه لكي تقبل يعني
فقلت انا عندي حكايه دعني احكيها لك وحكيت
الحكايه الفلسفه في السعوديه واشكالاتها
فقال لك علي ان انقل حكايتك هذا لاجتماع
مجلس القسم لكي نحصل لك على استثناء
لقبولك في القسم وفعلا هذا هذا الذي حدث
فكانت طبعا تجربه جميله في قسم الفلسفه في
جامعه فلوريدستيت
تحقق من خلالها الرغبه اللي انا كنت احرص
عليها